so the freedom 100 emerging markets etf
is the world's first freedom-weighted
emerging markets equity strategy in the
form of an etf so my background in these
two countries china and the u.s and
spending time in hong kong after college
gave me kind of a sense of the
importance and the impact that freedom
made in my life and and in these markets
we think that freer markets have more
sustainable growth they recover faster
from drawdowns and they use their
capital more efficiently both human
capital and economic capital and they
experience less capital flight and
capital destruction and so we want to be
in places where companies are free to
act in their own best interests instead
of the best interests of the state one
of the challenges we had in the
beginning was there was no quantified
metric for human freedom there was for
economic freedom but nothing on the
personal freedom side we define human
freedom as personal freedom and economic
freedom because we think those freedoms
work together and they're interconnected
you can't be half free so you have to
have both we actually had to create our
own human freedom
quantification system and then we had to
put a provisional patent on that
thankfully by the time i actually went
to score countries
frazier and cato had started doing their
human freedom index data set so now i
use
completely third party data that is
quantitative and if you look from the
beginning of history of mankind
freedom has gone up in slope and
drastically over time now freedom
increases we found in our studies are
very gradual and freedom decreases are
very sudden so it's the decreases that
we're noticing right now and they tend
to be set in we do have a portfolio rule
that
limits the
exposure we have to that downside
but
as far as the freedom levels over time
we do see an increase in over a long
period of time but currently we're
seeing a decrease i think another good
point to make here is that there is no
100
free market and there is no 100
oppressive market so
the ripple effect is an interesting
question because
just like autocracies have a ripple
effect and we've seen that in recent in
the recent past
so does freedom and we've seen that in
the recent past we see with the
president of ukraine and
even though he was a smaller force than
the russian military
that
his stand for freedom
changed the whole world's perspective on
it and i i'm feeling that as the manager
of this fund so
i hope the ripple effect in the end will
be that investors will direct their
assets towards freer countries countries
that are promoting peace and freedom in
the world versus countries that are
promoting other things like
oppression and slavery so i hope that is
the end game of the ripple effect and in
the meantime i hope that more people
will consider this type of strategy as
one that one aligns with their values
and two generates outperformance in the
long run
you